on va faire un tour laurent le terrain
pour gilles et sa petite famille
c'est le meilleur moment de la semaine
une balade dans jaffa le plus vieux port
du monde construit il ya 3500 ans à la
même époque que les pyramides
égyptiennes
mélenchon à droite ce sens un labyrinthe
d'escalier de ruelle qui mène parfois
quelques surprises comme cette orange
est suspendu et letters est l'un de ces
convois de l'eau gilles ne se lasse pas
de jouer les vacanciers et là il ya un
enjeu
les enfants jouent à l'ange ici et y
avril il adore à faire l'ange fait un
tour ici ouais je crois que tout le
monde se sont un petit peu touristique
fides que c'est une vieille ville n'est
pas un petit peu à l'écart de
la ville moderne et et c'est pas rien
n'a effectivement rien de vacances il y
a neuf mois gilles a quitté paris avec
sa femme abigaël et leur fils gabriel
ils ont décidé de venir s'installer à
tel-aviv
je n'avais même pas trop de monde qu'en
cas du top qu'elle a marqué qu'à la
marque crevettes et mme merkel doit pour
le moment
gilles ne parlent pas un mot d'hébreu
c'est abigaël israélienne qui prend les
commandes
sarah venir un jour et un miracle va
arriver dieu va me frapper
en venant s'installer ici il a pris une
décision difficile s'intégrer dans le
pays de sa femme
en israël une zone sensible nous on est
arrivé c'est encore la guerre au mois
d'août et c'était un peu surréaliste il
fallait si on n'avait pas su si je
n'avais pas été au courant des
informations et que j'étais arrivé sans
savoir ce qui se passe
j'aurais même pas su vraiment qu'il y
avait la guerre ou quoi que ce soit mais
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle toujours
tel-aviv la bulle c'est que comme pour
beaucoup dans beaucoup de facteurs c'est
c'est quelque chose qui est un petit peu
préservé du reste du pays
la bulle un surnom bien à propos pour
décrire cette ville hors du commun
beaucoup de français l'ont d'ailleurs
bien compris ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à venir s'installer ici
tel aviv une ville longé par 14
kilomètres de sable et de palmiers une
eau à 22 degrés en moyenne
ici on vit à la plage plus de neuf mois
de l'année c'est un petit bout de
californie en plein coeur du
moyen-orient et pourtant
israël n'est qu'à 4 heures d'avion de
paris une architecture tout en contraste
entre ces tours modernes et ses petites
maisons
on la surnomme la ville blanche avec un
dynamisme économique incroyable la ville
a réussi à devenir la deuxième place
forte des nouvelles technologies juste
derrière la silicon valley
de quoi attirer des petits génies du web
comme ilan à 40 ans cet entrepreneur a
réussi à se faire une place dans le
monde des start up
[Musique]
je fais ma propre vie j'ai montré que tu
peux faire ça c'est moi j'ai reçu tout
le monde pour essayer mais tel aviv est
aussi connu dans le monde entier pour
ses fêtes et ses nuits qui ne s'arrête
jamais ne dort plus en plus apte à peu
près vingt ans les gens nus dans le par
ils ont toujours peur de rater quelque
chose jack tropez à la tête de plusieurs
boîtes de nuit s'est très bien adapté au
rythme local
[Musique]
mais sous ses airs de paradis tel aviv
est une ville qui se mérite
la vie est chère et comme l 1 il faut
travailler dur pour s'en sortir
il fit tout le monde à deux ou trois
travail je veux dire à tous les français
qui viennent et quand vraiment envie de
réussir
j'en connais pas beaucoup qui aiment le
matin à 8 heures avec qui nous avons là
tu as tort comme elle
cette année près de 10 mille français
pourrait poser leurs valises à tel aviv
la ville la plus en vogue du moyen
orient
pour gilles et abigaël l'après midi
commence tous les jours par quelques
coups de il n'est que 14h30
et pourtant ils doivent déjà allé à
l'école chercher leur fils de 10 ans
gabriel
les écoles israéliennes allait vers 1h
1h30 la fin mais ici c'est deux heures
et demi du lundi au jeudi deux heures et
demie le vendredi midi il se passe que
les enfants peuvent rester à l'étude
s'ils veulent faire des activités mais
nous le nôtre il sort directement vers
le voilà idée là bas depuis l'arrivée de
la petite famille en août dernier
gabriel est inscrit en classe de cm1 au
collège français de tel aviv
le passé simple et l'horreur
c'est dur c'est un an
[Musique]
d'une part parce qu'il parle quand on
est arrivé
les connais pas bien les pour
et puis c'est bien moi je pense que les
le programme 37 et un peu plus exigeant
que l'éducation
les ardennes un peu moins exigeante
aller à l'école française en israël
gabriel lui aussi il n'y voit que des
avantages il a le double de vacances
aussi tes vacances israélienne de
conquête et je gagne beaucoup papa s'est
crashé en france tâche et on casse à 10
minutes de l'école au sud de la ville
dans un quartier populaire
gilles abigaël et leur fils se sont
installés il ya seulement quelques jours
dans un appartement typique des années
1 120 mètres carrés qui leur coûte 2200
euros par mois ça c'est un immense salon
c'est un grand salon qu'on a avec qui
donne sur l'ouest et spacieux certes
mais un peu vétuste et bon c'est pas en
très bon état et beaucoup de choses à
retaper
il ya des fils un petit peu partout
c'est pas aux normes françaises assez
clair qu'importe
gilles écrivain et sa femme photographe
ne peuvent pas se permettre plus surtout
que les premiers mois seul abigaël était
habilitée à travailler ici sur le machin
quand on est étranger et non juifs
c'est un peu plus compliqué gilles a dû
attendre cinq mois pour obtenir un visa
de travail
ouais j'ai eu un permis de travail en
janvier n'a pas pris trop de temps
finalement
parce que je suis marié à une
israélienne mais pour quelqu'un qui
n'est pas qu'il n'y a pas de connexion
au fait qu'est pas mariés ou n'a pas de
visa de travail pour qui n'est pas
employé par les sociétés françaises par
exemple à tel-aviv cochon ça c'est très
difficile de trouver du travail d'être
autorisés à travailler une fois le
précieux sésame en poche
reste le plus dur travailler en israël
nécessite de savoir parler hébreu et
pour gilles ce n'est pas encore gagné
alors je m'étais petites étiquettes sur
les choses pour en français avant les
mois pour apprendre les mots mais
comment on a déménagé tout est parti
c'est dommage
la brique à brique ou l'assaba 6h
plaisir parce que sert à l'avs se dire
le lait je peux lire les mots basiques
je peux lire les mots basiques et auch
la difficulté de l'hébreu c'est surtout
qu'il n'ya aucune voie y elle seule
solution connaître par coeur tous les
maux nooon ce match
tamas et à voilà je sais pas s'il n'y a
pas de voyelles faut je devine les
voyelles faut je me suis même si c'est à
eux ils ont eu et c'est comme si en
français on avait des mots ses marques
et au lieu de dire sucre on avait scr
des banques grecques c'est très
frustrant pour réussir à parler comme un
vrai israélien à 54 ans il va devoir
retourner sur les bancs de l'école
tel aviv c'est un peu l'équivalent d'une
ville comme lyon avec plus de quatre
cent mille habitants
c'est la deuxième ville la plus
importante du pays après jérusalem de
ces bars animés du centre au souk le
marché incontournable
[Musique]
tel aviv bouillonne dans une constante
activité un rythme de vie qui convient
parfaitement à elsa 23 ans
cela fait cinq ans qu'elle habite à tel
aviv ça va et elle a déjà ses petites
habitudes
elle commence de bon matin chez son
coiffeur mais pas question pour elle de
se relaxer
elle est agent immobilier et toute la
journée ça va être la course
ok d'accord et vous avez besoin avec une
terrasse sont pas du tout
imam le propre au téléphone une dame
l'appel de paris pour qu'elle lui trouve
un appartement en ville
ok d'accord bon je vote numéro dès que
je rentre quelque chose comme ça je vous
appelle une marseillaise d'origine
elle a quitté ses parents à 18 ans pour
démarrer une nouvelle vie
elle a fait trois ans d'armée en israël
et a obtenu la double nationalité
puis elle s'est installée à tel-aviv au
sein de la communauté française
quand on est jeune et sans ses parents
et sa famille c'est plus pratique pour
nous d'avoir des amis si à côté de de
s'intégrer plus facilement de trouver du
travail plus facilement donc je pouvais
pas aussi à l'habitude dans une ville
qui avait pas la paire à côté ce que
j'aime marseille et que
et que c'est une base chez nous il faut
qu'on ait la paix à la côte et finançant
pas bien parfait top on peut commencer
la journée
john son coiffeur est lui aussi
marseillais d'origine il a monté ce
salon avec son frère il ya un an
si elle a viens ici c'est pour retrouver
un peu de ses racines françaises mais
aussi pour faire un peu de business
donc en fait là on va montrer un
appartement à john il s'installe avec
son grand frère
donc du coup il cherche à déménager
faire passer
c'est ça la voix magique
son premier client de la journée c'est
donc son coiffeur
il souhaite trouver un appartement plus
grand pour lui et son frère
elsa la compagne dans un immeuble de
standing à une rue du bord de mer prisé
par quelques célébrités c'est l'immeuble
les soeurs kardashian racheter donc
beaucoup il y aura de belles voisine
fait il aime bien son peuple dans
l'immeuble des soeurs kardashian il y un
luxueux 80 mètres carrés entièrement
meublés ok donc comme tu vois là tu as
un petit salon très sympathique
il est très bien meublé tout ce qui est
l'arrêt ce salon grande cuisine 2
chambres 2 salles de bains charges
comprises
il faut débourser 2500 euros par mois ce
sont les mêmes loyer qu'à paris mais le
plus ici c'est qu'il ya un parking privé
le moins c'est cette vue
ben on l'a vu elle est pas top john mais
c'est très ensoleillé la journée
après c'est tel aviv quoi genre c'est
l'inconvénient convard et tel aviv c'est
qu'on peut payer vraiment des loyers de
2000 2500 euros et avoir une vue sur les
poubelles en bas très sympa vraiment
c'est très très sympa vous attendiez à
ces prix là on arrive en oui un peu
quand même parce que on voit que
l'immobilier avec pas de monter ici donc
pour avoir quelque chose d'assez
convenable et assez coisy si je pense
qu'il faut mettre le prix cuisine toute
équipée et si john prend l'appartement
il devra avoir un garant et faire douze
chèques davance antidaté pour payer la
première année de loyer une pratique
très courante ici que rechignent à
adopter la plupart des français plutôt
très exigeant quan des français qui
avant d'être elle aussi c'est qu'ils
veulent pas vraiment faire de
concessions ça veut dire on a des gens
qui viennent et qu'ils me demandent un
parking une terrasse un appartement beau
et meublée dans une dans un bel immeuble
ça existe pas à tel aviv on vient en
israël pour la qualité de vie mais on
vient pas pour le confort de vie c'est à
dire qu'on va gagner moins d'argent ou
avait dans un appartement un peu moins
luxueux qu'à paris ou en n'importe où en
france mais on va vivre dans un pays
qu'on a choisi donc c'est un des
avantages et des inconvénients
on y va qu'ai je parle avec philippe et
tu as une fois encore tapoter la visée
beaucoup jouent merci à temps à ce soir
et entre nous il va le prendre
ouais ouais ouais parce que je lui
montre des produits ça fait à peu près
un mois je le commence à comprendre ce
qu'ils recherchent et recherchez
n'existe pas donc
donc du coup je sais qu'ils aiment un
petit peu les chouettes un petit peu
luxueux son frère vient de los angeles
il aime bien les immeubles un peu comme
ça qu'ils aient les mêmes qui sont beaux
et c'est là ça va faire sur elza n'a pas
de salaire fixe
elle touche une commission sur chaque
location environ 50 % d'un mois de loyer
elle enchaîne ainsi une dizaine de
visites par jour alors c'est quoi le
problème
pinsker soit en a bien répondu trois
mille ont 3 on peut commencer voilà on
peut commenter des pôles évident quand
on voit la tour auquel elle n'a pas fait
d'études
elle a juste passé en quelques semaines
un diplôme qui lui permet d'exercer
agents immobiliers c'est le job le plus
accessible pour tous les français qui
s'installent ici
malgré ses allures de station balnéaire
où il fait bon vivre tel aviv se tient
toujours sur ses gardes
en témoignent les hélicoptères qui
sillonne la côte et les haut parleurs
pour avertir les plagistes en cas d'
attaque les dernières roquettes ont été
tirées depuis gaza 70 km de là en août
dernier alors tous les immeubles du pays
sont adaptés comme celui dylan un chef
d'entreprise de 40 ans se désole pour la
rentrée si une sirène retentit tous les
habitants de l'immeuble doivent
descendre à la cave
donc ça c'est un abri entièrement
briquet doublé avec tu vois tu peux voir
une partie qui est métallique
s'il ya un immeuble s'effondre donc ça
ça reste solide pour que tu puisses pour
que tu puisse garder tant qu'un maître
vivant qu'on va sortir de sa bulle une
des causes par fiat
mais il y a de quoi s'occuper tu vois en
fonction de la poussière que c'est un
fait depuis longtemps qu'ils ont pas
joué les gens le bull s'est pas de
dormir la brillance et d'être ici de 3 5
minutes
ce que sinon je m'en fous on vit avec ça
quand je disais et quand tu viens avec
ça tu profites du moment dont je préfère
rire que pleurer si le pays est connue
pour son climat de guerre il est
nettement moins pour sa place
prépondérante dans le high tech et c'est
justement ce que ilan est venu chercher
en venant s'installer ici il y a quinze
ans
tel aviv a la deuxième plus grande
concentration au monde de start-up juste
derrière la silicon valley aux états
unis il s'en crée une tous les jours
[Musique]
ilan a aujourd'hui 20 salariés mais il
est le seul français ils sont encore peu
représenté dans l'univers du web store
mais entre mm scharner il a ouvert sa
boîte il y a dix ans avec 2000 euros en
poche et la certitude que c'est là qu'il
fallait être que gens sont beaucoup plus
branché au niveau du monde digital on
n'a pas de pétrole donc on a en a on a
des gens qui sont intelligents qui
essaie de développer des solutions pour
le concert pour le domaine du médical et
j'ai vu un j'étais enthousiasmé que je
peux être une partie de cette révolution
aujourd'hui il est spécialisé dans le
design de site internet
il en a déjà des centaines à son actif
se retrouve en moyenne les salariés
restent à peine deux ans car ils partent
quasiment tous monter leur propre start
up
ici tout est fait pour aider ces petits
génies de l'informatique à développer
leurs idées
c'est à tel aviv que la célèbre
application de navigation wade a été
créée elle a été revendue plus de 1
milliard d'euros à google avishai et
yaniv des copains dylan bière à la main
n'ont pas l'air mais eux aussi ont fait
fortune en revendant leurs start
je me souviens quand on a commencé à
travailler ensemble
il était dans son garage dans sa cave et
maintenant il a un empire aol et
smarteam à dassault systèmes indiqué
moins 300 depuis 15 ans maintenant vous
êtes millionnaires alors
surtout on a très envie d'aider les
nouveaux leaders de demain avec les 45
millions que leur ont rapporté ses
ventes
les deux hommes ont monté une structure
très en vogue et tel aviv un incubateur
de start up
non seulement ils financent ces jeunes
geeks à coups de millions mais en plus
ils leur loue un bureau ou même une
simple table pour démarrer leur boîte à
moindre frais et aurait un quoi de neuf
je vous présenterai à 30 ans à peine
oren a déjà vendu sa première start-up
c'était une boîte dans le domaine des
plats à emporter
c'est devenu la plus grosse appli au
monde pour se faire livrer à domicile il
en montrent une seconde aujourd'hui et
tente de réitérer l'exploit des
structures pour aider les startups
il y en a plus de 75 en ville
tel aviv c'est un peu un grand village
où tout le monde se connaît elsa ne
déroge pas à la règle et même plus elle
est devenue une petite star locale
alors je vous donne mon numéro au cas où
si vous avez besoin elle ne peut pas
faire un pas sans qu'on la reconnaisse à
oui vous avez 23 que ce soir demande
elsa tout
à médecin un appartement c'est une fille
comme ça avec moi tomber dessus
attention elsa est consciente de sa
popularité et elle sait très bien
comment l'exploiter en chemin elle
retrouve une cliente d'un autre genre
ça va et toi gentle accompagné de sa
meilleure amie
donc c'est la mariée qui je m'occupe la
semaine prochaine
allez y en a c'est son deuxième boulot
organisatrice de mariage pour la
cérémonie de guendel elsa s'est occupé
de tout seul avec l acheter tous les
clichés pour les corbeilles je vais lui
gérer la cérémonie religieuse
on a fait quoi encore demain pour les
invités ouais les appartements pour les
invités bon un petit peu tout le cas
elle avait besoin quoi les aider à faire
un petit peu tout l'arrière plan du du
marel quand tout le gros bien embêtant
et aujourd'hui wendel a besoin d'elle
pour transporter ses corbeille remplie
de cadeaux dans un autre appartement
la future mariée habite à tel aviv
depuis cinq mois et elle aussi est venu
essentiellement pour la qualité de vie
par exemple à paris elle était elle
travaille et l étonnement du prothésiste
kong rhodésie sanguinaire et là le fait
ici qu'elle gagne contre la moitié de
mon salaire de france elle est payée ce
à quatre euros 50 $ pour le même travail
la moitié est elle travaille de 9 heures
du matin la dernière et les loyers sont
chers mais les salaires n'augmentent pas
c'est dur moi mais bon la vielle et bien
tarifs cela fait quatre mois qu'elle
organise les mariages de français en
israël
au départ elle devait juste s'occuper de
la promotion d'une salle de mariage mais
elle s'est servie de son carnet d
adresse et un senti une opportunité pour
arrondir ses fins de mois
j'ai vu que ça a marché pour le premier
un mariage de mariage trois mariages et
du de fil en aiguille en fête
j'ai connu un budget puis j'ai connu des
photographes puis j'ai connu des hôtels
donc je me suis dit pourquoi pas c'est
de l'argent facile c'est de l'argent au
sein pas élevé du bon et pourquoi pas le
prendre comme un travail ça c'est le
trap si elsa se démène autant c'est bon
tout vous plaît c'est parce que la vie
n'est pas facile pour les jeunes
français à tel aviv est là pour s'en
sortir
la jeune fille travaille jusqu'à 65
heures par semaine
bon je crois que les jeunes de notre âge
on travaille beaucoup d'heures ça ne
paraît pas quand tu es jeune qu'on n'a
pas de famille ça passe et ça ça on n'a
pas de famille pas d'enfant c'est pas
énorme d'avoir du boulot
un oncle être pas tout à l'erreur agent
immobilier
tu as bien les codes des portes
organisatrice de mariage numéro la
journée d'elsa est loin d'être finie
elle va bientôt entamer son troisième
jobs
si la vie économique est trépidante elle
connaît une seule trêve le shabbat
une fête religieuse qui rythme la vie de
tous les habitants
le vendredi à 15 heures les magasins
tirent leurs rideaux et la ville se met
au ralenti c'est enfin le week end pour
ilan et il a un rendez vous qu'il ne
manquerait pour rien au monde
à une heure de route au nord de tel aviv
haïfa c'est ici qu'habitent sa maman
bah en fait vaciller l'ogre entente
sylviane a quitté paris il y a dix huit
mois pour s'installer en israël
elle avait très envie de se rapprocher
de son fiston
ça me fait plaisir bien sûr de voir ilan
bien que il vient souvent le shabbat
mais pas assez soin regret
et voilà et alors oui l'alzette content
avec maman qu'il est proche de là dans
ma maman non je suis content j'avais pas
de famille pendant à peu près 14
ici je te tout seul la tradition veut
que l'on invite la famille et les amis
pour ce dîner du vendredi soir
et justement les voisins sont les
meilleurs amis de sylviane
voilà ça va daniel et mireille n'arrive
jamais lu mains vides
comment weill hannecart à shabbat
il faut que la table soit bien garni et
un hommage
au menu salade de poivrons de betteraves
caviar d'aubergine et le fameux couscous
bull est super bowl de mam
son péché mignon si pour les juifs
pratiquants le shabbat implique de ne
pas utiliser l'électricité ou encore de
prier ilan le pratiquer à sa manière
pour lui ce dîner surtout l'occasion de
s'extraire de la frénésie de tel aviv
c'est à battre la ville c'est tout le
temps je cours chez tong rendez vous
d'affaires nous redonner 100 % à mon
équipe à mes clients la vidéo comment un
bon business de quand c'est le mot
décanter une soirée au calme et en
famille pour ilan à tel aviv par contre
l'ambiance est radicalement différent à
la tombée de la nuit les rues et les
terrasses se remplissent la ville ne
dort jamais
dans cet immeuble un peu impersonnel au
cinquième étage se cache l'un des clubs
les plus courus de la ville les jeunes
le valium à sa tête
jack que tout le monde appelle jacques
tropez un français de 44 ans et qui
peine à se mettre en place tous les
soirs vers 10 heures
chaque été la ville depuis 20 ans c'est
le roi de la nuit vous dit jacques raupp
et tout le monde le connaît
et pour cause c'est l'un des seuls
français à s'être imposé dans le monde
de la nuit à tel aviv
une ville qui compte pas moins de 60
boîtes de nuit alors pour faire la
différence
jack s'est offert ce soir là les
services d'un dj français venus
spécialement de paris et payer 1000
euros l'heure
[Musique]
le voyagiste est pour
pour m on appelle ça de munir izard
fait
le pays
mais dans la capitale du clubbing un dj
parisien ne suffit pas jack doit
s'entourer d'une armée de petites mains
appelez les rp pour relations publiques
l'ag des tables puis les attendant moi
je prépare le champ des jeunes au carnet
d'adressés bien rempli
chargé de ramener une clientèle huppée
venus du monde entier radar c'est les
américains jack nous maintenons tous les
français on a un italien
on a même un mexicain au mois d'août
mexicain alors nous avons une critères
de sélection ce soit en tout les très
belles filles rentrent gratuit entrée
gratuite pour les garçons en revanche ce
sera 20 euros par tête
s'il vous plaît
payant pour les garçons gratuit pour les
filles c'est assez banal
on se croirait presque dans n'importe
quelle boîte de nuit sauf qu'ici la
fouille au corps est obligatoire dans ce
pays en guerre
on n'est jamais assez prudent le risque
d'attentât et partout et tout le temps
quant aux attaques aériennes il faut se
tenir prêt à chaque personne qui habite
à tel aviv ont cette application ça
s'appelle red alert va dès qu'on est
attaqué par par l'étranger ça se met à
sonner
il ya marqué tel aviv attention au
bassin vous avez une minute pour vous
planquer dans un dans un abri c'est
aussi pour ça qu'on fait la fête
différemment ici c'est peut-être pour ça
que chaque personne chaque israélien
quand mon avis vivent au jour le jour
une vie au jour le jour
ces israéliens veulent profiter s'amuser
comme n'importe quel jeune de leur âge
[Musique]
une aubaine pour jack tropez qui en 20
ans et créer un petit empire avec ses
associés il a ouvert trois discothèques
à chaque fois il s'est inspiré de son
expérience passée dans les soirées
enflammées de saint tropez avant en
boîte de nuit les israéliens ne
consommer que des verres d'alcool
aujourd'hui grâce à jack et à son
concept ses clients commandent de plus
en plus de bouteilles les plus
extravagantes
3 litres stabilisé mais ça ça coûte en
euros à peu près 1200 euros oui et pour
ceux qui auraient très soif vraiment
très soir ça c'est ça c'est très courant
en lavant hall avons très souvent et ça
ça coûte à peu près dans les 2000 euros
j'ai déjà des clients déjà trois quatre
clients qui veulent mettre ça juste pour
le prestige
c'est papon pour le boire pas
automatiquement ils vont boire de trois
verres et puis et puis se termine
des bouteilles pour la frime qui
rapporte gros
plusieurs milliers d'euros par soir et
ce n'est pas prêt de s'arrêter
après le monde de la nuit le businessman
français veut conquérir un autre marché
encore plus ambitieux ce serait même du
jamais vu à tel aviv
le lendemain
si certains dansent sur le bord de mer
[Musique]
gilles lui est d'humeur studieuse
cellule aura fais tes devoirs
ok c'est ma camarade de classe je copie
serait tout le temps pour mieux
s'intégrer à la société israélienne
gilles prend des cours d'hébreu depuis
trois mois deux fois par semaine il
vient dans cette école du nord de la
ville dans sa classe
on attend une douzaine d'élèves dont la
moitié française
les autres viennent des états unis ou de
russie première leçon décrire ce qu'il
voit sur cette photo si frias effrayant
si free aktan arym iyashi nîmes v skyrim
rattaché à gilles s'en sort bien mais à
54 ans pas évident de revenir sur les
bancs de l'école
surtout qu'à cet âge on est beaucoup
plus critique sur la qualité des cours
ce que je trouve si on fait trop de
choses un petit peu académique des
choses clic on peut pas vraiment utilisé
lundi
pratique c'est vrai ça fait trois mois
qu'on fait qu on est on sait toujours
pas comment dire comment échanger
supermarché bon j'ai pas fait du jeu
gilles est un élève assidu qui
participent beaucoup pendant les cours
vais-je ishaya fa d'hashim ya faute
apprendre l'hébreu c'est loin d'être
évident mais pour les français qui
s'installent ici c'est un passage obligé
ils sont d'ailleurs de plus en plus
nombreux à s'y mettre ces deux dernières
années j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait un
nombre croissant d'étudiants français
qui arrivent en israël
vous l'avez remarqué dans cette classe y
en a beaucoup ce sont de bons élèves
gilles est abonnée d'elle aujourd'hui
n'a pas fait une seule erreur il a
répondu correctement à toutes les
questions
alors il progresse je crois qu'il a un
bon professeur oui en classe ça va parce
que j'ai préparé mes devoirs j'ai tout
fait j'ai vu le problème c'est que quand
on le veut on sort dans la rue tout de
suite que c'est dieu plus difficile
d'autant plus compliquée qu'à la maison
il ne parle pas hébreu même avec sa
femme israélienne
bonnet des monnaies des pizzas à nous en
occuper un mot je trouve fatigue est là
je suis trop fatigué après deux heures
et demie d'efforts pour la chercher la
pizza ok bon bah tout d'abord l'un d'eux
vraiment le cas 8h50
on pense que c'est facile puisque mon
fils parle hébreu m par les bois mais on
parle français à jour c'est trop long je
suis trop débutants pour obtenir une
conversation quand on est le soir chose
à faire
voilà c'est comme ça mais je perds pas
espoir
je perds pas espoir
après avoir passé la nuit à travailler
dans ses discothèques
c'est l'heure de la détente pour jack
tropez en fin de matinée il vient fouler
le sable déjà bien chaud des plages de
tel aviv
[Musique]
là c'est le matin voilà ça le matin il
fait déjà 35 degrés c'est en 1994
lorsqu'il passe ses premières vacances
en israël qu il tombe immédiatement
amoureux de cette ville où il fait bon
vivre
à l'époque il n'a que 23 ans le premier
jour premier jour où je suis arrivé j'ai
voulu rester basse et pressé un plein je
cherche exactement ça et je trouvais je
suis arrivée là ça ce qu'elle est cette
qualité de vie la plage
bon travail de nuit équilibre qu'est ce
qu'il me fallait une vie de fêtard la
nuit des moments de détente le jour
révolté ce quotidien là aux côtés de sa
femme et de ses deux enfants jack ne
l'échangerait pour rien au monde même
pas pour sa ville de coeur qui l'a vu
naître
marseille a d'abord
non ici c'est un peu le paradis et
marseille c'est mais je suis marseillais
à tout jamais revu toujours être fiers
d'être marseillais
hello
les mardis votre tour
je retrouve en vue oui bien sûr oui non
non non non non non c'est vous annonce
rend cette année je suis là maintenant
peut-être ailleurs mais bon peut-être
dans une dizaine d'années quitte
retraite à saint tropez
je mérite mois mais avant de penser à la
retraite jack a encore des projets
ambitieux le roi des nuits israélienne
veut maintenant s'imposer dans le monde
impitoyable de la restauration
voilà les travaux du restaurant avec son
partenaire ya qui il veut faire là
encore la différence ça c'est le
restaurant ça va être un restaurant
italien
au moins on pourra privatiser tous
ordres et pour ce restaurant
il a eu une idée qui peut paraître à
première vue banale en israël proposés à
sa carte des plats cacher ça c'est
normal non pas du tout a tel aviv n'a
rien à partager c'est très rare les
rations à la restauration car à tel aviv
non c'est très rare il ya très peu alors
on a décidé de faire un instant cacher
mais dans le luxe dans le haut de gamme
ce restaurant ils ont imaginé dans un
hôtel de luxe du centre ville à laitages
jack et son partenaire ont même prévu un
bar lounge pour se détendre après avoir
mangé là tu vois on voit la hauteur de 1
m à fond là on fait une reproduction
géante d'une vieille couverture de
playboy l'ouverture de son quatrième
établissement est un défi de taille pour
jack
tu vois un peu comme ces grands à 44 ans
il a encore l'ambition d'un jeune
premier
bon ben c'est pas fini on n'est qu'au
début
début de carrière pour vous aujourd'hui
il est plutôt israélien en français et
israélien sera un lien mais avec
l'accent français
nul doute que jack tropez le plus
israélien des français réussira son
nouveau pari elsa l'agent immobilier et
organisatrice de mariage entame son
troisième jobs
c'est parti
tenue de soirée et talons hauts elle est
dans les starting blocks depuis cinq ans
elle et rp pour une boîte de nuit ce
soir ici on y attend 5000 personnes
c'est un des plus gros night club de la
ville et le mieux situé
la voyant on est vraiment sur l'eau ça
veut dire on est vraiment proche de la
mer c'est en plein air ne fait pas chaud
les gens peuvent parler la musique et
pas très très très forte
et puis c'est surtout vraiment un
environnement de vacances remboursant
durant la journée
elle a rameuté tous les jeunes français
pour les inciter à venir ce soir c'est
une clientèle extrêmement exigeante mais
elle a scellé chouchouter elle leur
réserve les meilleures tables clermont
et c'est tout
tout ce coin là en fait de là où je suis
jusqu'à la fin des ballons c'est tout
l'endroit où tu veux vip de la boîte et
c'est seulement là que les français
aiment tatouage c'est seulement là aussi
que les grosses tables sa slate et les
clients qui ont de l'argent et tout donc
vous verrez ce soir les français ne vont
pas à l abri les mettre là
une très bonne table peut dépenser ici
jusqu'à 2000 euros la soirée
et ça monte jusqu'à 4500 euros pendant
l'été là encore elsa n'a pas de salaire
fixe doit avancer juste avec elle touche
10 % de commission sur les consommations
combien de variabiliser angie ce cas
plus graves
alors elle espère que ses clients
viendront mais surtout qu'ils
consommeront le plus possible chalosse
c'est la soirée la plus prisée de tel
aviv
certains jouent des coudes pour y entrer
ce soir rien que pour elle il y a dix
sept tables réservées et pourtant elle a
va avoir beaucoup de mal à placer tout
le monde ici les responsables de la
sécurité sont très strictes
il faut avoir au moins 21 ans pour
rentrer
les trop jeunes elles font pas rentrer
et 95g vraiment pas moi qui l'est c'est
ça je vous promets et elsa va devoir
gérer un problème beaucoup plus en béton
chien bam et à l'est d'abéché machine
rien il ya juste potable
[Musique]
prat la wii pour faire rentrer rana et
ses amis elsa imagine un petit
stratagème elle lui demande de donner un
faux nom et lui attribue la table de
quelqu'un d'autre pourrait les rappeler
[Musique]
ridha minimum heineken
cris ôta et des jours amarrés aux quais
yuda reste à la table ont été installés
pas si un pilote c'est un petit peu
compliqué mais en fait les gens qui
arrivent après 11h30 c'est très
compliqué de rentrer il faut qu'ils
aient beaucoup de patients et il ya que
les clients habitués qui rentre pas
facilement
tu
elle a réussi sa première mission faire
rentrer tous ses clients
[Musique]
américain tel aviv c'est la patronne ya
pas lieu si tout le monde est content
elsa n'est pas totalement satisfait de
sa soirée
son plus gros client n'a dépensé que
1800 euros
elle attend impatiemment l'été et les
touristes français qui dépensent deux
fois plus et la jeune femme a commencé
sa journée à 10 heures du matin et la
termine à 4 heures mais pour rien au
monde elle ne rentrerai en france prénom
la vienne en israël c'est évidemment la
rade à dire sur tous les points même si
on travaille
elsa ne compte pas arrêter de cumuler
les boulots et dans l'avenir elle
voudrait organiser plus de mariage
jack lui devrait accueillir les premiers
clients de son restaurant dans une
semaine si tout va bien
ilan espère toujours trouver la
prochaine star du web
quant à gilles il fait des progrès en
hébreu jour après jour
tous ne sont pas prêts de quitter tel
aviv
[Musique]